so tom
elon musk sends a tweet out
and somebody asked him david lee on
december 24th ask him a question
says personally i think elon musk is the
best investor of capital
an innovator at scale in our generation
that might be an understatement
kyle if you have that tweet if you can
pull it up that might be an
understatement
this is an opportunity to create a
structure
that would optimize his time and
interest the most
right and then elon musk responds
in engineering designing general company
operations observe vast majority of my
mind and are the fundamental limitation
on doing more capital allocation is
important but low cpu load
tesla publicly public company duties are
much bigger factor but going private
is impossible now parentheses
side okay yes side now
while you're looking at this tweet with
what he says what it does the tesla
stock tom is going to give us an update
on that here's what ends up happening
gm's 27 billion electric electrical bet
begins with bad boy hummer truck the
giant automaker plans to push out 30
electric vehicles by 2025
to take on market leader tesla inc
starting with the two most iconic brands
at the top of its roster cadillac and
hummer
gm is spending 27 billion dollars in an
all-out effort to remake
40 of his lineup and re-tool one-third
of its us vehicle assembly factories
putting it in a one-way path to
electrification tesla is aggressively
building more production
around the globe the president elect joe
biden and other political leaders
elsewhere are pushing more ev-friendly
government policies
that will help plug-ins as uh sell like
tesla ceo elon musk bera has an
advantage over rivals such as ford motor
company volkswagen ag
plenty full supplies of its own
batteries co-develop with partner lg to
chem ltd the much better anyways this is
going to talk about who can potentially
compete
jim is also boosting that truck will go
450 miles
before needing hr tom what what happened
when elon musk sent this tweet out on
christmas eve
well the stock went up because
everybody's like oh he's never going to
take it private so it was kind of the
opposite of that thing yeah
ready to go private funding secured and
the security exchange
commission said all right buddy pull
over license registration please
you know and what nuts what i think
people forget is
he is still the leader in ev monstrous
leader in ev
you know he has 80 markets here in the
united states all these great big
articles about gm and everything gm's
very capable company they're giving up
cadillac and hummer high-end cars that
are very expensive there she is
that's maribera what she was saying
right there is dear god please make my
stock grow up when i say the word
electric
dear god please make my stomach no no it
was
kind of like a rosary she just kept
repeating and it didn't really help at
all she stuck at 60 billion in market
share
which um they sold about eight there's
an interesting stat they sold like eight
million cars
this year approximately and at 60
billion dollar market cap that's about 7
500 bucks a car
so you got to say that one more time so
they sold 8 million cars
in 2020 correct and then the market cap
is 60 billion
correct okay so it's about 7 500 per car
if you just use that as a measure
and if you contrast that with tesla
which is 60
600 600 billion dollar market cap
and they sold about 435 000 cars this
year um but it wasn't for pandemic they
would have touched half a million cars
this year
so that's 1.4 million dollars per car
sold so
in terms of future value and what people
think
elon musk is two universes ahead
but gm's gonna catch up they're gonna
catch up and figure it out
and you know the model s is old it's
eight years old but it's nice
so elon musk is about to be in a more
com going to go from the leader status
to a guy that's got other sharks in the
same pool with him
but i i don't bet against him but this
feels a little bit to me
like the empire strikes back like here
comes the second chapter of the movie
is what i feel like is coming you know
gm only sold 110 000 cars this year
that's 1.4 yet this is their website and
you look up there
gm's path to an all-electric future
never mind 98.6
of our cars still use dead dinosaurs so
it's
is this fear is this strategy is this
urgency is this the right strategy
what would you say about this i i think
it is i think it's fear and urgency
right now and i think they're trying to
move their their stock and they're
trying to get out of front of it i do
think it's fear and urgency right now
um because tesla you know is ahead but
the one that i would fear if i was elon
musk not fear but keep an eye on
is gm because of the battery supply
chain because right now the battery pack
of the car
is still more expensive than the
internal combustion engine
still more expensive interesting those
lines will cross we know they cross
with with volume today you know led
lights
very environmental and everything and
nice light in your house use a lot less
energy
you can go buy a pack of 10 for about 40
bucks
at home depot now you just go back eight
nine years ago
a single led light bulb was like 50
bucks
and now you're buying them in super pacs
the same thing's kind of the batteries
and when those lines cross
people like gm are going to get volume
on their side
and push so he's got to put out new cars
he's got to keep driving
tom let me see let me give the math one
more time what you just said this is
very important i don't know if you guys
caught this or not did you guys catch
what the matthew gave or
okay so here's pay very close attention
to what tom just said
gm sold 8 million cars
8 million cars not 800 000
cars 8 million cars and their market cap
is 60 billion
if you take 60 billion you divide it by
8 million tom's getting
7 500 dollars they're making this year
right this year
now now if you take is it eight is 7 500
or 75 thousand times is it 7 500
75 if you take tesla's market cap
600 billion but they only sold 435
so gm sold 8 million cars they're worth
60 billion
tesla sort 435 000 cars there were 10
times
more but they sold 20 times less cars
and if you break down the 600 billion uh
by how many cars they sold the average
car they sell is 1.4 million dollar
profit to them
you got you understand how this market
is right now saying what tesla's worth
so here's what i read about an article
tom wrote yesterday on vtps.com
wells fargo is saying tesla
is about to be the next aol in 2021.
this is wells fargo
wells fargo is not a smaller company
wells fargo says
tesla's about to be the next aol so
either the market
is infatuated with the ceo and they're
making the value of this company go to
where it's at today
or tesla's about to be the aol which one
is right
well he is a rock star okay and that
is a big big part of it and you know
what i think a lot of attention gets
placed on this because we're so sick of
the negativity all the other news the
coronavirus
you know uh the the warring factions
between the democrats and the
republicans i think some of this he gets
so much publicity
can he be oversaturated pretty soon i
mean is can he be overexposed sometimes
i think
there's almost too much elon musk but
the guy is so brilliant
and he keeps delivering i will say this
i've never been an electro
electric car guy you know and i'm not
really a car person but you know what
yesterday have you ever owned one or no
i'm not okay but i live in california
which is the home of it where everybody
has one
so yesterday i i have a diesel suv
and there's one gas station i can go to
where in california it's 3.33
cents per gallon as opposed to 3.63
cents a gallon so i drive there
and yesterday i'm thinking i just spent
25 minutes of my day
going out of my way to this gas station
so i could save 30 cents
on completely overpriced gas the way it
is i want to get an electric car
i went to the mall because i had to you
know one day over the holidays
all the good parking spots are electric
they literally build the infrastructure
of parking lots right now
for you to charge your car office
buildings where my office is in la
i mean you want the best primo spot it's
where the electric hookups are
and you know what i'm in and i think
this is the next arms race
i mean that's why apple's involved this
thing is going to get crazy because the
whole world
is gonna want and need an electric car
and i'll make one last point you know
who should go into the electric car
business not saying it's easy
but should exxon right why can't they
spend
you know 500 billion in in research and
development and come up with their own
because they're not going to sell any
gas
that would be hilarious if exxon went
into the car business
okay i have been holding my tongue for a
minute but
for wells far i have no love for wells
fargo wells fargo was the nice bank that
opened extra
credit cards and extra accounts for you
without telling you about it
suffered a huge federal uh and they lost
their ceo
and your criminal charges were filed so
i i think that there's a bit
of um you know overreaction there is
does tesla kind of come back to earth a
little bit on this valuation over time
sure they are but i don't bet against
the entrepreneur and the
and pardon the expression the engine
that is in elon musk's heart
he's not just going to sit by and let it
happen we're going to see
you know remember we thought that the
that the lineup of cars was getting
boring
and and elon musk kept saying boy you
know our car is getting kind of boring
we got to do design things
he was saying that for three weeks
remember that remember what he did he
goes on stage with this
incredible weird truck announcing the
tesla truck
and it's like oh okay the super truck
and i'm moving to austin so he knows
what he's doing he's got a whole
funnel of things to do what it was one
thing i would say
is what you're talking about moving over
to energy you know
i saw a list of the plug-in
infrastructure players and the number
two ranked on number of new parking
spots installed is bp
british pearl petroleum correct yeah
yeah so one so this part of my arm from
my elbow to my fingertips is doing
electric
the rest of my body bp is still selling
diesel natural gas and stuff
what was interesting you and i both know
a guy uh evconnect in los angeles jordan
raymer
we were in a ceo council together
remember
jordan raimer evconnect he is he was out
there
making infrastructures an entrepreneur
out there
becoming a reseller of energy and
building the infrastructure
so that a mall could put in the parking
spaces and he was trying to convince
people
don't just make it a benefit for the top
three spots
because the first spots were for
handicapped and then we have pregnant
mothers
socially really good ideas to do that
and then we put the evs up there now
wait a minute there's nothing wrong with
someone driving an ev
but they get to be closer and jordan
riemer went out there with this dream he
just said
hey i think we should build entire parts
of parking lots and everything
and so i think there's a lot of
entrepreneurship going on there that
it's only gonna
it's only gonna help but i'm not betting
against um
i'm not betting against elon musk pat
i'll make this comment and i'll be
interested to see your
reaction to it i think some of elon's
competitors
see a vulnerability with him and here's
what it is
he runs two other businesses he has
spacex
he has that boring company that's
building the tunnels in la and vegas and
everything
and he moved to austin so his companies
are in out in california
and he's over here do you do you think
he's minimized by the fact that he's the
ceo of these
huge huge globally changing companies
something's going to suffer and i would
imagine a smart guy like a tim cook
and the people at gm and their
competitors are thinking
you know there's part of his day every
day he's not devoting to tesla
and does he have enough of a army behind
him
to make up for he's the man running the
show so
years ago i mean ilan i think he's got
four or five kids he's got he's got a
good amount of kids i don't know the
exact number where he's got four or five
kids
and i think he wrote about it in an
article written by
neil strauss a very lengthy article
great article written about him when
they were doing an interview and one of
the reasons why
he decided to you know go be single
is he wanted to marry his career now he
does his best to be a father but he
doesn't want to have any kind of full
commitments he definitely wants to be in
relationships in and out but he wants to
be able to commit
to his businesses his babies are the
companies he runs
he treats his companies like his babies
that's that's where he's at i remember
one time i sat down
with a former cfo of aig okay and
him and i were having dinner where you
know you weren't there we were in ritz
carlton chicago
and he's sitting right next to me and
this is when they went and got the money
from the government 183 billion dollars
and i said so you know tell me about
yourself you know he says well you know
i do this i said how many kids you got
he said i don't have any kids really
you're not married so no
i'm married how long you guys been
married we've been married for 25 plus
years how come you don't have any kids
my wife and i made a decision a long
time ago that our babies was going to be
our career
we were going to dedicate that energy
into our
career not kids and we felt kids were
going to take away time away from
our career now think about you have kids
you have kids yep i have kids i got an
eight seven and a four and one underway
right
you got uh dash and ivanka you got brook
and bailey right
how many total hours has been put into
his kids
actually think about it i want you to
actually think about it
how old is bailey how old is brooke how
many total hours of
your time have you put into your babies
wow don't don't say i would not replace
it i'm not talking about that
i'm just asking you think about yes how
many of your life
hours was put into your kids diapers
park picking them up dropping them off
talking to them
sitting down everything's gonna okay how
many hours
it's in you can't even count them plus i
have a daughter named brooke as well
she's just graduated from pepper that's
how pepper died yeah she grew up in the
bay area all the time i flew back and
forth
how many hours it's actually i think i
want you to think about it
i'm trying to think about it if you were
to think about it put the hours what do
you think that hours is for you
is it in the tens of thousands yes is it
in the is it in the thousands
okay so if you have those tens of
thousands of
hours that you put into your kids to put
into something else
how would they do so you have to
understand
the fact that that that the part about
putting time into his babies i think
he's got plenty of time
all right i don't think that's a
challenge for him to do now as far as
him being exploited and can they get to
him and all this other stuff
you know when when you're going into the
nba there's a couple different kind of
players
you're going to major league baseball or
nba there's a couple different kind of
players there's players that
want to play with who michael because
they're enamored by it
like you know how they when jordan came
back and he went to the wizards
the bench could never play he says my
teammates wouldn't play because they
would just stand there not play defense
and rotate
because they were watching michael
they're like oh my gosh i'm enamored by
my play the damn basketball game right
but there were also guys like kobe
coming out saying dude i'm not scared of
you
you know i'm coming for you there's
going to be people that are going to
want to compete with iran
that's just that's just you know that's
true but wanting to compete with him
and maybe not being that next level
thinker and genius that he is you're
already starting behind the edge
you are but there's going to be somebody
the market tells us there's always
somebody that comes out
that wants to do something it's just
it's always been like i also think tesla
has to stay cool
i'm not excited about a gm electric car
now i am excited about the hummer that
you had mentioned
that they're going to come out with the
new hummer that's going to be electrical
why don't you talk about what they're
planning on doing with cadillac by 2025
this is a pretty strong statement made
about cadillac and i think it's a smart
statement
and it comes out of this fact here's a
simple fact for you
if you take away the federal subsidies
and the discounts that are paid for our
government on the
cars tesla is not cash flow positive on
each car
think about that even at half a million
cars a year they're not
cash flow positive so we need these
federal subsidies
green air subsidies so that you can do
this
that's number one very important gm
knows this
and gm knows that because of batteries
the cars are going to be expensive for a
while
so i think gm made one really very
good strategic move in maribyra's
announcement
where she was saying please god make my
stock go up and that is
they're sacrificing cadillac as a gas
brand cadillac is going to be an
electric brand
it's more expensive there's a higher
price point
there's more features that are inside so
they're going to do that
so that the brand and its cost lines up
with the underlying more expensive cost
to make an electric car i think that's
smart i think that's smart and they're
saying hey by 2025
hummer is a cool announcement cadillac
is more of a consumer point of
tesla-esque move some volume people who
are willing to pay 80 grand to 100 grand
for a cattle occurring now for a gm
so for every hummer you sell you'll
probably sell five of those little cx's
i can totally see that so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye